hey everyone this is Steve vilantro with
collider and I am in the collider Studio
sponsored by Saratoga spring water thank
you we sponsors are important
um and uh I'm here with boots Riley who
has an upcoming uh Prime video series
yeah that is going to be coming out I
actually don't know when it's coming out
when is it coming out
he can't say I heard it yeah exactly so
uh yeah but we are premiering it
at a different Festival South by
Southwest so you'll start hearing
people's reactions to that then so
listen I have a ton of questions about
this series and just a ton of questions
but for people that actually don't know
your work and you have done a lot of
work in your career like where do you
want people starting you know do you
want them starting with like the feature
you made do you want them look where do
you want them for I don't think that's a
that's a good entry point is the feature
and then uh they can go to uh listen to
um an album called pick a bigger weapon
they can then go to an album called
genocide and juice
um they can you know there's a lot to to
but but yeah the movie that's why I made
the movie that's a a thing you can sit
down and watch and also you know we did
the soundtrack to it too so yeah well
tune yards did the score but we did the
soundtrack uh also the movies fan tune
yards is doing the score to my
TV show as well so let's jump into it so
that it's called I'm a Virgo and it is
from what I understand about in fact
what am I saying why don't you please
so it's a it's a
it's about it's an absurdist
Fantastical ride with a 13 foot tall
black man who lives in Oakland
California
it's called I'm a Virgo and you know
that's what's important to him about
himself
you see a giant walking a giant black
man walking down the street to a lot of
people that's not important to them the
the fact that he's a Virgo but that's
what's important to him
um Jarrell Jerome does an amazing
job and uh people are going to be
looking at him with different eyes after
this one we've got
um also Walton Goggins Mike Epps
um uh Carmen a jogo and some other folks
that people will see as as discoveries
Cara young Brett gray which a lot of
people under the age of 20 won't see
think is a discovery but uh but a lot of
people they're they're all doing amazing
jobs and then we even have a lot of
really cool cameos from uh uh Kendrick
Sampson
um Elijah Wood
um Le Keith
um you know I mean there's it's just
packed full of a lot of cool [__] my
thing is that oh sorry yeah yeah I I
could keep going I'm gonna I'm gonna
forget people so whatever I would
imagine after sorry to bother you that a
lot of people were calling or wanted
meetings with you to discuss what do you
want to do next so what was it about
this story that said this is what I want
to do next
well so I had
this idea and three other movies and
they're all going this is just the one
that's coming out first
so it was
this was you know a lot of times you'll
write stuff and it's really about things
lining up in time so I have basically
I'm making a I'm I'm making what I'm
calling a cinematic album of which sorry
to bother you is the first single and uh
and and the season one of I'm a Virgo is
the second one and then my other three
movies go into that so it's all part of
a a larger plan it's not one Universe
these movies but it's kind of
uh and
a a weird view from from my point of the
world right what was it like for you
because making a feature is a lot
different than making a television
series so did you enjoy the experience
of making TV in a way that that's
something like wow I really I want to do
more TV now that I've experienced like
you know what I mean because it's
completely it's very different it's very
different
um
I think I'm a fan of stories that end
so TV is not necessarily what I want to
to stay in but the way that we're doing
this is something that is is different
than that I I really
um don't like the shows where they just
keep you hooked keep you and keep you
going just to keep you going because
after a while you feel like oh you
really don't care what you're saying as
long as I watch the next time so
um and as a viewer I feel insulted by
that and so I don't want to make that
kind of stuff
um I think with a TV show there are
there's there are there's a lot more
bureaucracy how do you say that word
bureaucracy to the process that um I
don't get in feature films so
um you know it's a it's a different
animal I don't think it has to be but
that's just the way it's set up
um if I if I can ask how many episodes
is I'm a Virgo it's seven
and was that a number that you came up
with based on story or I love the number
seven
um I like it upside down
and I like the way it looks I like the
the angle that it makes and so I was
like whatever I do it's going to be
seven got it so this game no I'm just I
was gonna be I don't know
no
no I mean I
I don't know I don't come up with the
number and then it's just what it ends
up being sure but my thing is that
sometimes like the studio will say we're
looking we we're interested in six
episodes and then but the story dictates
I want to do seven I don't you're more
experienced at that than me because I
don't know this is my first time doing a
TV show and uh you know I try to stay
ignorant to certain things because my
brain you know like Sherlock Holmes he
doesn't let
sure every piece of information into his
head I have to ask you about though so
the your main protagonist your character
is is 13 feet tall what is it like
trying to pull that off so that's that
was part of so really
that's part of the answer to your first
question is why this one first
um we did most of the stuff practically
meaning forced perspective
puppets
we also have stop motion in the show we
have all kinds of stuff and so I want to
make the process fun and now that being
said that doesn't mean there's no VFX in
it but there's no not really any CGI
there might be a couple little things
but you know like I really feel like
with CGI you can
have a CGI skyscraper that stands up
walks over and takes a [__] and it
wouldn't be amazing right but and that
should be amazing and that's why you
have to use practical things so that
when that building takes a [__] you're
like I feel that I see the textures and
all that kind of stuff and so
you know with this we had you know
uh
had to do everything in two scales right
we had to build a half scale this a have
a full scale that and all this kind of
stuff and
um yeah I don't want to get too much
into how the sausage is made until
people see it because I don't want
everyone thinking about that and that's
the amazing thing about it is that you
see it and you just feel the difference
you don't necessarily like oh I see that
they did this and I see that they did
that right listen I I commend you
because I listen practical is the way to
go all the time because it make you you
believe it like you see it it's actually
and it ends up taking a lot more
um
preparation to do that so in order in
order to do this for the budget that we
needed to we had to really plan so we
had to storyboard almost everything
almost the whole show right before him
and so that we could be like this is
what we have to build
these are the lenses we're going to need
this is what you know all these sorts of
things because I mean if we were like
say another show on the same network
that got a billion dollars as a budget
then we could just do it much faster and
just build everything both sizes and um
then we wouldn't have to prep as much we
could just go out to lunch and then
start shooting but I actually think that
preparation though probably adds a lot
to the it makes you really think about
every shot and do you really need it
yeah exactly
um exactly before I run out of time with
you you mentioned you're working on
other features as a big fan of your
first feature uh can't talk about it
is it something but if you're a big fan
of the first feature
same guys making this show
right and and so it's always going to be
you know I'm always looking for ways to
talk [__] and you know and and that's
the most important thing to me like I I
want to say the [__] I'm gonna say and
uh whether it's
here with you or
you know doing music on stage or
film or TV
it's the vehicle and that that and I
really think that people have to have a
passion that's that that's that they can
something they care about more than they
care about making the art because that's
the thing that drives you helps you
decide what are the shots I'm gonna get
is this good is this important is that
otherwise you'll be asking everybody
else and you still ask everybody else
but you don't you know you need your own
divination rides 100 my thing was really
about do you think you'll be in front of
cameras this year in front of cameras
meaning like you think you'll be filming
your next movie this year oh yeah yeah
but if I get in front of it I mess up
the shot
what I'm saying is I just I'm looking
forward to I'm a Virgo and I'm also
looking forward to what you're going to
do next yeah and we will be shooting
other stuff this year
um listen man uh I hope I have I cannot
wait to see it sincerely and I hope to
be at South by to be able to see it when
it plays there yeah but uh listen man
I'm I really it's gonna I'll tell you
this whatever you think it is it's a
little bit crazier than that and then
now imagine that in this just a tiny bit
crazier than that one cannot wait um
thank you so much for coming in to uh
talk all right thanks for talking to me